thank you guys we're here with the world
champion dominant player for over a
decade magnus welcome to the studio tell
us about today's game today d5 seem to
shock you but you responded well
yeah i don't i don't know i probably
should have should have known that move
um
when he went five e6 uh i mean i thought
that was a bit of a strange move earlier
if he's gonna go knight f6 so i
figured he was gonna go d5 then i
thought man maybe it's not so good
and then
yeah i actually kind of
missed his reply in the game um
it had to reply exactly no um 11 knight
f6 i just um i just missed because the
queen was was on f6 in the other lines
so the fact that the the knight would uh
would appear on f6 also where it's not
really protect protecting its its king
was a bit
uh was a bit surprising but fortunately
for me it's um
yeah it's still uh
it's still a draw aft after after that
which i think was uh
was a pretty uh pretty fair result
overall so knight f6 caught you a little
bit by surprise what were you expecting
i didn't know what to expect really like
i think when you're
encountered with uh with the surprise in
the opening where the position is super
sharp you don't think you have a lot of
expectations you just try and try and
hold on somehow and
yeah
some sometimes you can even get a game
but this is normally what happens that
it just turns into some kind of force
draw
magnus we have to ask the big news came
out today you're not defending your
world title does it feel
lighter how do you feel no it's okay i
mean i've been in this mindset now for
uh for over a year so obviously it's uh
um
you know
when it's when it's official it feels
feels a bit weird but i'm i'm fine with
that i'll
continue to to play a bunch and then
try and uh
you know just do as well as i can tell
us a little bit how what this means to
you as a player will you be as
competitive are you still trying to get
to new heights or are you slowing down a
bit
no i mean i think for a few years now i
haven't been as competitive as
i as i used to be but i still want to
play chess and i still want to do
do well
it's just
i'm i mean i don't
i'm perhaps not quite as yeah
i don't have the the same
the same quite the same drive but that's
that doesn't mean i'm gonna play a lot
worse no absolutely you're still
dominant in showing great chess tell us
a little bit what this means to you as a
person will you be dedicating time to
other activities
um we'll see
i i have um some some ideas don't know
if what they'll
what they'll come to really um otherwise
you know i still love playing chess
so i'm gonna do that a bunch and i have
to ask you the world championship match
won't have you do you think that the
value of it goes down without having the
world champion defend and the best
player
uh yeah i guess so but that's not really
that's not really my my problem oh
absolutely thank you magnus we have
plenty of chess ahead for you guys back
to the studio
thank you alejandro and thank you for
your questions